tandis qu'au loin les combats se
poursuivent
c'est secouriste recherche d'éventuels
survivants
ce quartier de marioupol est désormais
sous contrôle russe
après plus de quarante jours de siège
non mais nous pensions que la pire chose
c'était un bombardement aérien mais en
fait il n'y a rien de pire qu'un char
quand ils se déplacent et que vous êtes
allongé sur le sol vous pouvez entendre
le bruit du canon en mouvement c'est
très effrayant et vous ne savez pas où
il va tirer cette vidéo montre des chars
russes détruit autour de la dernière
poche de résistance ukrainienne elle a
été fourni par le régiment azoff une
milice fondée par l'extrême droite dont
les membres font partie des derniers
défenseurs de la ville tandis que
l'armée russe continue de se redéployer
dans l'est du pays le président
ukrainien lance cet avertissement jeu
rooney nous avons entendu une
déclaration des occupants confirmant
qu'il se préparait à une nouvelle étape
de leur terreur contre nous et nos
défenseurs
l'un des porte parole des envahisseurs a
déclaré qu'il envisageait d'utiliser des
armes chimiques contre les défenseurs de
marioupol nous prenons cela très au
sérieux les séparatistes pro russes
affirment désormais contrôler la zone
portuaire de la ville sur facebook les
membres de la 36e brigade de la marine
ukrainienne qui défendent aussi
marioupol écrivait ce lundi nos
munitions s'épuisent nous ne savons pas
ce qu'il va se passer mais nous vous
demandons vraiment de vous souvenir de
nous avec un mot gentil
selon des sources militaires
occidentales
il restait encore trois mille soldats
ukrainien
retranché dans les ruines de la ville